hello everyone I'm Alana welcome to my
channel where today I'm going to be
talking about the Hands-On opportunity I
had with redifol a few weeks ago which
is arcane's latest game if you don't
know them uh they're best known for the
Dishonored series they may prey they
most recently made death Loop I'm a very
very big fan of Arcane but I also
recognize that they seem to have a bunch
of trouble marketing their games which I
think is to their credit they make games
that are difficult to explain and that's
kind of difficult to Market and so I
took a bunch of questions from you guys
about redfall and I would say majority
of them were like what is it exactly so
I will do my best to explain also before
we go any further please excuse
situation with this eye I have a boxing
match in three weeks which means I am
getting hit in the face pretty
frequently and um this is what happens
but yes last time I mentioned that
people like you have a boxing match so
I'll also leave a link in the
description to a way you can check out
more information about that announcement
in case you missed it you will be able
to watch it it's a lot so to the
question blue three or three love I said
I've heard redfull compared to Far Cry
how do you feel about this comparison
after playing it I would say redfold is
much closer to Far Cry than the original
comparisons that we got uh regarding
left for dead it is not at all really
like Left 4 Dead um I feel like the
gameplay of something like Left 4 Dead
is very corridors
hordes of enemies occasionally a big
enemy comes and fights you very Co-op
focused experience while this game does
have co-op it's not even necessarily a
co-op focused experience um we did not
play at Co-op at the preview event while
I think they do currently still have an
online only requirement I believe that's
being addressed like maybe we'll be able
to change that before launch at least I
think I saw somebody got a story saying
that but yeah the preview we played
completely solo and uh even if you are
playing co-op with three other people in
your world with you you can all be doing
completely different things you don't
even have to be doing the same Quest you
would just kind of exist in the same
world I know that's technically not what
you asked but yes it is not like Left 4
Dead it is much more like Far Cry and
frankly probably the most like
um video gamey the most standard the
most familiar kind of game that I think
Arcane has made there are a lot of
powers that are very similar to those
that you would find in Dishonored or of
course death Loop which in a lot of
cases is literally just Dishonored
powers in death Loop and they've
expanded on some of those and changed
some of those of course without four
different Heroes but Far Cry is not a
bad way to explain it so we did get to
play through or at least I did get to
play through one story Mission
um that was effectively
get to location at the stealthy away and
I'll shoot you away and I chose to self
my way in because there are a lot of
different enemy types I guess not that
different to Far Cry and some of them
are very punishing I was actually really
excited specifically about the enemy
variety that's something that I don't
feel like uh they've done a ton of in
previous Arcane games and it's really
ramped up here the different types of
enemies do such different things and
there are some that you'll see and
you'll be like oh I don't want to mess
with that at all the ones that I was
confronted with in this particular Story
Mission that made me go stealth are
called watches and they generally are
perched up on you know somewhere high
and they'll just stare at you and you'll
kind of see the line of sight it's like
a vampire version of a far cry
Watchtower where somebody would be you
know scanning an area for you and then
got inside of this house and in a very
Arcane level design fashion basically
had to find a bunch of items
um and the way that I found them was by
seeing where they were inside of a doll
house and then transferring that
dollhouse
sorry about my dog chewing a bone in the
background
seeing where they were in the dollhouse
I then had to go in those places in the
real house unfortunately did have to do
the same thing uh three times in a row
and honestly level design is like my
favorite thing about Arcane or about um
dishonest specifically and I love
dishonest one and two I actually loved
Dishonored too like that is I don't know
in terms of level design like probably
one of the best games ever made I think
it's fantastic but I don't feel like
it's unfair to say that it is like a an
Arcane take on Far Cry I think that's
probably pretty fair again a lot of
differences you are playing as these
four Heroes that have their own move
sets and and um styles and abilities and
the enemy variety is very different to a
far cry where it's just like a heavy
because you are fighting against
vampires not against humans so it
certainly like blows that concept up and
is much more creative but it does have a
lot of similarities but yeah for the
story Mission we played um I wasn't
super impressed with its story wise in
terms of like the writing um it was it
was interesting but uh a little bit
cliche and the only thing that was kind
of a bummer about that is that you
effectively had to do the same thing
three times so you just three step
separate times had to navigate this
house and go to the same spot to collect
things three times in a row which um I
definitely would have liked a bit more
variety there but I still thought that
conceptually and again in terms of the
actual level design it was very cool
whale we've said was there a lot of
diversity in the builds for the
characters in rainfall or is each
character mostly meant to do one
specific thing uh we only go to play one
unfortunately I would have loved to have
swapped between multiple characters but
we only got to play one each so I'm sure
if you went to see other people's red
full coverage you'd see different takes
on the different characters but yeah I
was only able to play the one picking
was really hard I went with the
character called Remy who was
effectively like a combat engineer she
has a little robot called um I think
it's briben or briben Ribbon who I fell
in love with very quickly it's like so
hard not to like fall in love with a
robot companion at this point in games
it's wild how quickly they get you but
you can send him out to distract enemies
to like send off this signal and they'll
all sort of swarm onto him but you can
also do some cool creative stuff like I
I put C4 on him and then sent him out to
blow people up and thankfully he
survived but you can also throw the C4
and detonate it so um those are her two
things that make her different to
everybody else but I don't think the
hero differences again from my
perspective having only played one of
them are so dramatic that you feel like
you'd be tied into any playstyle because
every character I believe can get access
to every weapon and I will say
death Loop was a step forward this is uh
even better in terms of the actual gun
play the shooting combat is arcane's
best by a mile the the shotgun
specifically I found just so so much fun
I feel like they've just consistently
like iterated and iterated um in terms
of Gunplay it's such a weird phrase and
that this is the the strongest uh for
that yet I had a real great time
shooting stuff and yes so basically
every hero character can use every
weapon I believe it's just their
abilities though are a little bit
different Jacob is the shop shooter he's
got a lot of self-focused abilities and
long range combat abilities he can cloak
I believe and then you can kind of send
him out to scout where people are and I
think there's maybe a level up in his
skill tree I hope I'm remembering this
correctly where he can also cloak the
whole party for a while which is very
cool and then his ultimate ability
creates um like a ghost power sniper
rifle basically but that doesn't mean
that nobody else can play stealthily you
will have to play through the game
stealthily again similar to previous
Arcane games sometimes certain areas
will just be like way too overwhelming
or with these different uh enemy types
in the enemy variety there'll be
situations that you just won't want to
approach all that they'll be a kind of
enemy that you're like I don't want to
deal with that right now I'm not
equipped to deal with that right now let
me stealth around it and the stealth was
pretty easy I think maybe a little bit
easier than previous
um Arcane games probably not easier than
death loop I guess um because this is
definitely a more action game from all
King but yeah there's nothing to say
that any of the other characters
couldn't use the sniper rifle um the
other two heroes are Layla and davinda
Layla has uh telekinetic abilities her
big thing is that she can create this
like elevator that can send people
upwards and I was having a lot of
trouble picking between Remy and Layla
because they both sounded the coolest so
she can like spawn something that will
shoot you into the sky kind of which
sounds amazing I guess the point of that
is it's helpful for reaching rooftops
and there are a lot of um houses and
buildings that some of them have
different purposes like you'll find
certain houses that are marked in a
specific way that mean that like there
are a lot of vampires in that specific
house and maybe you aren't ready to go
into that house yet there are areas in
the map it kind of act like raids which
I think is not really cool I didn't get
to try those unfortunately but yeah
otherwise she can soak up bullets with a
sort of Shield as well and then Davina
is a cryptozoologist I believe is what
is what he has this electric Javelin
that he can fire and zap anybody who's
around him he also has a teleportation
device that he can throw out and uh
teleport too of course and then his
ultimate is um a UV attack which uh you
do have a UV gun in Your Arsenal at
least we did where we started playing
and UV is helpful
um for vampires obviously especially for
the sort of Hive ones there's usually
going to be something stopping you from
getting a safe house because you do
unlock safe houses which I guess is one
of the Left 4 Dead comparisons you can
pick up missions there you restock
health and ammo there and you can get
more of these sort of hubs the one that
we started out with was a fire station I
don't think they're all fire stations
and you'll just have to kill a big enemy
potentially outside
um while avoiding this Mist that will
kill you in order to unlock those and
sometimes you have to get power to them
to be able to open them up as well which
is really just like a matter of chasing
a cable to make sure you plug it in
while you're potentially being attacked
and you can fast travel between those
points I believe at pretty much any
point in time which is cool but yeah I
also believe the more safe houses you
get the more
um
missions you can get so on your way to a
safe machine you'll likely pass by a
safe house you might want to stop in
then
capture it reclaim it and I guess that's
your ultimate goal is to eventually take
full control of redfall from the
vampires but yeah sorry the question was
where was there a lot of diversity in um
builds I think everyone is going to suit
any kind of play style because you have
access to all the different weapons but
you do have those Specialties and
they're basically just like cool
additions to traversal um or some
different abilities so I don't think it
matters too much you could still
probably play without ever using your
abilities definitely wouldn't recommend
it but uh with any weapon that you like
essentially so not a huge deal but I
will say that the skill tree was very
very extensive it was big oh hello there
b dot PNG said is redfall solid as a
single player game even though it has
four player co-op
um
I you like I said we played it single
player you definitely can play it single
player this game does feel like it is
suited very well to co-op and I think I
am unlikely to play it single player
it's just not as compelling to me as a
single player experience as the other
Arcane games have been like death Loop
which is something where I'm like you
know dealing with the puzzle that is
that game
um I actually love playing Dishonored
with other people uh not Co-op obviously
but like with other people in the same
room I'm actually a really big fan of
that so that one's like kind of in
between but
um I feel like the
the story that we saw
was not very much of it and the gameplay
Loop to me is not as
engrossing as arcane's previous games to
play as a single player experience so I
do feel like it's benefited by playing
Co-op again I don't feel like I've
played enough of it to really
confidently say this but uh that I I
intend to play at Co-op for sure and
then I feel like currently I would
recommend it as a co-op experience and I
think as Co-op it'll be like
unbelievably fun especially because you
can all do different stuff you can just
go into the map and do whatever you want
you don't have to do missions together
you can obviously like you could you
know have somebody see something really
cool and maybe over your mic they'll be
like hey I just found this really cool
thing you want to come join me and
you'll just teleport to them and join
them and it sounds like that that's
gonna be the the most appealing way to
play the game oh and of course
um Borderlands is a really really great
example of what this is like Borderlands
is probably more apt than Assassin's
Creed or destiny to be honest it's very
Borderlands
in in a lot of ways
um but I think I even based on the small
amount that I played I preferred it to a
Borderlands 3 for example and there is
like slightly more creative stuff that
you can do in the world as well um like
you have rewired kits you have lock pick
kits and you can use them to access new
areas open loot stashes you can even
rewire gun turrets that you'll find
throughout the world and if you don't
rewire those and you run into one they
kill me faster than almost anything else
the gun turrets are brutal you can also
like disable car alarms so uh that added
sort of an interesting approach to how
you want to get around the world like
how stealthy you want to play or don't
want to play and one thing I should
mention there as well is that everything
that you do
um this didn't happen to me but I know
that it was slowly occurring is noticed
by the vampire gods they call them if
you start causing too much Mayhem you'll
get like a meter that will slowly fill
up sort of like uh stars in GTA and if
that maxes out a vampire God will come
and find you something super powerful
super scary so you'll have a boss fight
I imagine that they just pursue you
until you be eat them or die I'm not
really sure but that was actually very
exciting and added a cool layer to like
how much chaos you're causing which
again kind of Arcane DNA Cody said as a
gameplay of red for feel as smooth and
fluid as other Arcane games oh
definitely yes
um I had my fair share of bugs this was
of course a preview build but my biggest
one was a lot of rubber banding so for
anyone who's not familiar with that term
I would be walking somewhere and then
just suddenly would like pop back and
forth in an area
um I had a few vampires who just like
didn't notice me or like glitched around
an area so there definitely were some
bugs but of course preview build it
happens uh doesn't mean they won't be
there on launch but they obviously have
time to fix it but otherwise definitely
um it it does feel like an Arcane game
TDOT 12 said is that much of a story to
redfall or is it like Left for Dead with
the story and they call it board style
or is it like death Loop that's all
story based what's the point of the game
um there is a story that I didn't
experience too much of I would say it is
not a story having as death Loop by any
means but also not as absent as Left 4
Dead it's probably somewhere in between
and the real point of the game is to
reclaim the island and there are a lot
of ways that you're gonna have to make
decisions about what you want to
approach next like um the vampire Nest
that I mentioned are kind of like raids
will slowly grow over time if you don't
address them enemies in those um areas
it's like a blue circle on the map will
be stronger because they're closer than
Nest as well so you could leave it and
then it'll just keep growing until it
overlaps with another Nest I think it
doesn't overtake the whole map or you
could take them all out at once so
figure out what you want to take out and
when uh it's really up to you and I
think that that's probably the main
point of the game though I don't even
necessarily feel confident in saying
that but that's what it seems like to me
it's better take the island and figure
out how you want to overtake the island
do you sweat 17 asked is redfull scary I
jumped a bunch of times actually it's
not like a traditional horror game by
any means and I don't think it has the
tension that something like prey or
Dishonored has at all I don't even feel
like it really has the tension of death
loot because I'm not as concerned about
dying but I definitely jumped a bunch of
times when I was like trying to avoid
having a bunch of vampires mob me
because they can be a little more
complicated to kill like for example if
you use a standard weapon on them you
can wear them down but you will have to
plunge them with a stake to actually
kill them otherwise they'll just get all
their health back they're vampires or
you can use
um a UV gun that will freeze them in
place and then you can just smack them
and kill them there's also a you'd set
them on fire with a flag on and I think
there's something you can freeze them
with as well so they are slightly more
complicated to kill than the humans that
also exist in the game that are like
vampire worshipers for the most part and
again like I said there's some good
enemy variety there so there are a bunch
of different types of vampires you have
to approach differently it was mostly
like any time when I was trying to
stealth in a vampire just snuck up on me
was when I was spooked but it's
definitely doesn't have the same amount
of tension as Dishonored which I feel
like is super tense all the time but I
certainly jumped to add it more than I
ever jumped in a far cry oh the mustard
said are the options available to tackle
combat scenarios and redfall as diverse
as they are in arcane's previous games I
imagine they probably are but I don't
think it's as necessary because it's not
as difficult so I think it would be
easier for you to run in and shoot stuff
where in other Arcane games you
sometimes just simply can't do that and
I didn't see like a mass amount of
different approaches like you know into
sonnet but that's what the whole point
of dissonant is really so it's not quite
comparable to that I'd say it's also
like to me personally probably the least
appealing of the Arcane games thus far
I'm very excited to try it called but
it's not quite as appealing to me as
um a dishonor of prayer a death Loop
which all games that I just absolutely
adore just because it's a little bit
different in fact I wouldn't be
surprised if this ends up being their
most popular game because I think the
formula is probably going to appeal to
more audiences
um just like in general across the board
than something like death Loop or
dishonorable prey do awesome so yeah let
me know if you have any more questions
or if there's anything that I missed but
I think I've answered pretty much
everything I can with the time that I
had with the game um it was super fun
I'm very much looking forward to playing
more of it with friends I'll probably
like do streams and gameplay videos with
that a ton when it comes out on game
pause so looking forward to that but
otherwise that is it for me to everybody
hi Moana I'll see you guys next time
[Music]